la parole est à monsieur françois van
sant monsieur monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique les collectivités territoriales
représentent 70% de l'investissement
public local il va donc sans dire que le
plan d'investissement de le plan
triennal de baisse de 30 % des dotations
des collectivités
cumulé à la hausse des dépenses sociales
un impact substantiel sur les capacités
d'investissement des collectivités
territoriales d'ici à 2007 à 2010 est ce
sont 11 milliard d'euros qui ne seront
pas investis dans le tissu local comme
l'ont souligné récemment la cour des
comptes les associations des nues cette
situation entraîne des conséquences
dramatiques pour les entreprises vivent
essentiellement de la commande publique
l'application de ces dispositions n'est
pas sans générer devise de vives
inquiétudes notamment chez les tpe et
pme et pme du btp qui sont les premières
touchées et dont le chiffre d'affaires
est déjà fortement impactés par ce plan
l'investissement public représente en
effet 50% du chiffre d'affaires de ces
entreprises soit un emploi sur deux de
plus cette baisse des investissements a
des effets préjudiciables sur
l'entretien des réseaux publics retarder
les investissements conduire à engager
des sommes plus importantes dans
quelques années en tant qu'élu national
et président de conseil départemental je
considère normal que les collectivités
participent à l'effort de redressement
des finances publiques notamment en
matière de rance de rationalisation des
dépenses de fonctionnement néanmoins ce
n'est pas en privant brutalement les
collectivités de leur capacité
d'investissement que nous parviendrons à
relancer la croissance de nos
entreprises par ailleurs nos
départements nos villes nos villages ont
de gros buzz
1 en matière d'investissement aussi
madame la ministre merci maman l'état
madame maryse lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
ses députés monsieur députés vent sont
bien évidemment vous avez raison il faut
que les collectivités territoriales
participent à la baisse des déficits
publics déjà divisé par deux mais
effective l'effort est difficile mais
regardez bien et regardons ensemble le
btp le cas de la capen toutes les
entreprises nous parle mais
reconnaissent avec nous que dans nos
choix apporter quelque 17 milliards déjà
d'euros du séisme pour nos entreprises
continuer avec la baisse des cotisations
sociales nécessitait un effort des
collectivités donc ces entreprises
bénéficient de cet effort de
compétitivité donc c'est compliqué c'est
vrai je vous la corde mais nous avons
réagi
nous avons réagi avec l'elysée
l'économie des finances ministre du
budget en priorisant l'investissement
nous avons remarqué aujourd'hui une
stabilité ou une hausse significative de
l'épargné brute d'un certain nombre de
collectivités territoriales va falloir
regarder en détail
celles qui souffrent et celles qui
souffrent mois mais nous étions devant
les sénateurs la commission des finances
vocaux lèvres l'autre jour avec andré
vallini leur disons que nous sommes
d'accord pour prioriser les
collectivités les plus en difficulté
avec le milliard d'euros qui a été
engagé son investissement nous avons
décidé avec l'aide de tout le monde de
faire un effort particulier sur le fctva
kirpan encourager encore nos communes à
l'investissement mais je le crois
monsieur le député nous réussirons le
tout lorsque nous serons juste il faut
que nous soyons juste en termes de
révision de nos critères d'attribution
de l'aide de l'état aux collectivités
locales après dotation qui ont une
histoire un peu difficile à faire
comprendre à nos concitoyens mais qui
crée des adultes les injustices il faut
que nous soyons justes sur la
péréquation et l'effort que nous faisons
avec les départements
nous vous devons le faire avec des
collectivités tout en faisant attention
à ce que la majorité des crédits que
nous avons pu économiser avec cet effort
des collectivités
a bien été dirigés vers les entreprises